et pour parler de cet appel national du
14 mars storia akroum gilet jaune
cheminotes et signataires de cette
tribune nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
tauriac um bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors comment est née cette volonté de
rassembler les colères en une
manifestation c'est d'abord une volonté
en fait unanime de ce qui s'est passé en
fait durant ces deux dernières années
notamment avec la colère des cheminots
en 2018 la manifestation verra la sortie
des gilet jaune en fin 2018 et la grève
historique on a connu dès le 5 décembre
donc c'est tout ses colères en fait
qu'on aimerait se voir traduire en fait
pas recette mais cette journée de
mobilisation le 14 mars notamment aussi
des la famille les familles des victimes
de violences policières qui seront là
aussi les écolos pour la marche contre
pour le climat donc tous toute ces
toutes ces colères en fait sont
rassemblées en une seule journée et donc
pour nous il était important en fait de
faire un appel à rejoindre en fait cette
journée alors vous appeler à une
mobilisation sur les champs elysées est
ce que vous ne craignez pas au fond que
certaines personnes profitent de cette
initiative pour en découdre avec les
forces de l'ordre nous en fait dans
notre appel il n'y a pas en fait de lieu
précis précis et précisé c'est justement
en fait dans le but de c'est vraiment un
appel un rassembleur pour dire aux gens
sortent et le 14 mars soyez tous à paris
et rejoignez la manifestation qui vous
plaira mais soyez sûr paris dans les
rues de paris le 14 mars après comment
cela va se dérouler concrètement sur le
terrain
sa seule la journée nous le dira mais
pour l'instant c'est pas c'est une
manifestation qui sera déclarée il ya
des manifestations il ya des parcours
qui sont déclarés d'autres qui ne le
sont pas et après on invite chacun à
faire avec sa conscience alors dans
votre appel vous parler d'un plan de
bataille a élaboré par tous dans quel
but finalement mais en fait on voit que
depuis
la grève qui a eu lieu en fait eux
malgré une forte mobilisation au niveau
des des grévistes et sur la durée on a
vu que ça pas abouti à faire
à faire tomber cette réforme donc
forcément on s'est dit qu'il ya un plan
de bataille à construire et ce plan de
bataille la construire avec les
différents secteurs d'activité qui ont
un impact sur l'économie
et forcément ça ça ne peut se faire
qu'en étant réunies au niveau
dans une réunion nationale et on appelle
tous les parlers secteur les syndicats
etc à rejoindre
à rejoindre en fait cette réunion cette
mobilisation qu'on continuera par la
suite pour justement en fait élaborer
une stratégie
donc voilà il ya des gens qui parlent de
la black week qui est une semaine noire
pour
pour justement impacter sur l'économie
d'autres essaient d'avoir une une
stratégie plus globale avec notamment la
fin l'énergie le lait
les raffineries et et d'autres secteurs
avec un impact plus fort qu'ils sont en
train de se concerter pour pareille
justement trouver une date commune pour
partir et
et dans une grève générale qui n'a
encore pas été comment dire il n'a pas
encore été un appel au niveau des
centrales syndicales
on n'a encore pas eu d'appel à la grève
générale des centrales syndicales donc
c'est ce qu' on essaie de faire en
construction avec différents secteurs
mobilisés
il ya encore des secteurs encore
mobilisés pour
appelés à 7 à cette grève générale et à
cette construction surtout alors le
président emmanuel macron assuré lors du
salon de l'agriculture
vouloir recevoir un groupe structuré de
gilet jaune
pourquoi finalement ne pas s'en tenir à
cette main tendue du président de la
république
1 parce que cette main tendue on va dire
c
la manière dont il l'a annoncé à la
personne qu'il avait en face
heller qui en avait l'air de rien il
avait l'air justement de parler comme un
pdg en fait tu reçois une heure entre
deux cafés et on essaiera de discuter
mais on sait très bien qu'il ya aucune
il n'y aura pas de sortie de crise suite
à cette réunion et puis
cet entretien puis une heure
pour faire quoi exactement enfin il a
avec lui les les
les centrales syndicales qui viennent
discuter avec lui
ça fait maintenant plus de six mois et
les a pas écoutés donc qu'est-ce que
c'est un coup ci gilet jaune
pourront espérer obtenir 20 après ça
c'est mon ressenti mais faut pas non
plus être fermé à sa proposition après
ça c'est dans
ça sera la décision personnelle des
personnes qui vont qui vont y aller
merci beaucoup tauriac room d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes je gila jaune cheminotes et
signature de cette tribune qui appelle
donc à une mobilisation le 14 mars
prochain à paris